[Music]
on this thursday night desperation
becomes deadly in afghanistan terrorist
bombs turn kabul's airport into a
bloodbath
canada's evacuation mission is over what
happens to those we've left behind we're
continuing
to do everything we can u.s soldiers are
among the dead how will the president
respond residents of a fire ravaged bc
village eager to return and rebuild
everything i had was in there plans to
prevent another devastating disaster
and election reflections asking if
you've decided how you're going to vote
i talk to voters about who deserves to
win
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
it is as far west as you can go in
canada we are in british columbia
tonight a province that in many ways is
the envy of the world vancouver
consistently ranks as one of the best
places to live and it's a place that
will play a key role in who forms the
next government of canada good evening
and thanks for joining us we are at
vancouver's maritime museum in kitsilano
the first stop on a cross-country tour
during the federal election campaign
but we begin tonight with events in
kabul afghanistan where danger has
turned to catastrophe
two bombings on the perimeter of the
airport and at a hotel have killed
dozens of afghans and at least 13 u.s
soldiers many others are injured
kabul hospitals are overwhelmed
the images from the scenes are deeply
upsetting we are not going to show you
the worst of them but a warning what we
are showing is disturbing
people died where they stood so crowded
into the area outside a gate to the
airport standing in a trench for sewage
water hoping they'd be on a flight out
of that country
that it was a bloodbath
these images were shared by a former
afghan interpreter who was safe after
the blast it's not clear if among the
dead or other afghans who worked with
canadian forces and were approved to
come here
an afghan branch of the so-called
islamic state has said it was behind the
attacks they are more extreme than the
taliban who can they consider the enemy
along with america and the west and now
that the us has handed the country to
the taliban more attacks are inevitable
many evacuation flights have stopped as
mike armstrong reports the future for
afghans trapped under the taliban is now
even more uncertain
they had gone to the airport to be saved
afghans desperate to get on a plane out
of the country instead dying or injured
waiting canadian officials say they'd
had multiple warnings in recent days a
terrorist attack could be coming
this man says he was at the airport
trying to get a visa to the u.s when an
explosion went off in the middle of the
crowd now there had been public warnings
the country is involved in the airbridge
operation on wednesday and told people
to avoid the airport that there could be
a terrorist attack
despite that thursday the crowds were so
big tear gas and fire hoses were used to
keep people back the area was still
packed when the bomb went off
this witness says people were thrown all
over some blown into pieces
the u.s led operation is now drawing
down several countries are flying their
last evacuation flights some like canada
are already done the chief of the
defense staff says only a handful of
canadian soldiers are left they've
stayed behind helping with logistics as
the international effort wraps up the
cds called the decision to leave
heartbreaking the taliban are the ones
who are restricting the ability of so
many to get to the airport to be
extracted so put the blame on them
please
canada's final numbers are now known
since the beginning about 3 700 afghans
were flown out but a thousand on the
last day what is not known is how many
have been left behind it's just non-stop
tragic news dave morrow is one of the
canadian veterans who's been working to
get interpreters and afghans who worked
with canada out of the country in recent
days they've been telling families to go
to the airport to look for canadian
troops
now they're trying to figure out whether
families they were trying to save are
among the victims
that's
afghanistan in a nutshell you know like
it's just it's it's just mind-numbingly
sad
global news spoke to an afghan man who's
been trying to get to canada he was near
one of the explosions thursday we're
protecting his identity but he says his
years of work for canada have now made
him a target in his words it's ruined
his life and not just his
i've got four kids two boys and two
girls and now they're live in jeopardy
as well
canadian officials insist efforts to
save more afghans will continue but
getting people out was hard enough when
there were resources in the country very
soon there will be nothing at all mike
armstrong global news
there have been multiple terrorist
bombings by isis k in afghanistan over
the last few years they just didn't get
much attention in the west this because
of the tolling because american soldiers
were killed has drawn in western leaders
including the american president joe
biden spoke not long ago let's go to our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
jackson what was his message
well donna president biden acknowledged
the difficult circumstances here and the
heartbreak felt by the families of those
american soldiers he also made it clear
it's time for the war in afghanistan to
come to a close and so the evacuation
mission is going to proceed and wrap up
as planned by august 31st
keep in mind that today's attack was the
second deadliest single incident
involving u.s troops and the entire
20-year presence in afghanistan this was
also exactly the kind of attack the u.s
had warned about in recent days
president biden says the u.s is going to
continue to work with the taliban to get
americans and allied afghans out of the
country he vowed those behind today's
attack will not go unpunished
for those who carried out this attack
as well as anyone who wishes america
harm know this
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
tough talk jackson but it is a mess the
evacuation mission was already ending
thousands left behind is there any sense
of what happens now
well things are obviously much more
complicated there are still about a
thousand u.s citizens in the country
perhaps up to 250 000 eligible afghans
waiting to leave as well the pentagon
acknowledges though that there are
ongoing threats from isis k that could
include attempts to shoot down the
planes carrying people out of the
country or perhaps drive car bombs into
the airport but the delicate in-person
work that the u.s marines were doing
today is actually going to continue
amidst all that the soldiers who were
killed today were actually doing
physical screening of people approaching
the airport pat downs and bag searches
putting themselves at grave danger to
carry out this mission the pentagon says
it's now asking the taliban to expand
the security perimeter around the
airport and president biden hinted that
the u.s is also looking for ways that
would allow people to leave the country
even after the u.s military mission
concludes next week
okay jackson in washington thanks now
the canadian response justin trudeau is
on the campaign trail as liberal leader
but he is still the prime minister he
has to handle canada's response and
answer questions about what happens now
abigail beeman is traveling with the
liberal campaign abigail
donna justin trudeau was asked again and
again today what is his message to the
people left behind and where is the
accountability for not getting them out
faster he didn't answer but he did
stress canada will continue to help this
particular moment is done and it's
heartbreaking to see but there is much
more to do and canada will continue to
be there
for afghans and the afghan people
trudeau said canada will continue to put
pressure on the taliban to let people
leave although he wouldn't elaborate as
to how we're continuing to do everything
we can both
to bring tens of thousands of afghans
with their families to canada
but also to keep putting pressure on the
taliban
to ensure that people can leave
afghanistan and come to canada trudeau
stressed the canadian commitment to help
resettle 20 000 people from afghanistan
but he didn't tackle the issues around
the red tape and clogged bureaucracy
getting in the way of getting people out
he seemed today to blame the speed with
which the taliban took over from making
things more difficult though he's been
criticized about that since people
watching the region knew these tensions
were boiling over for a long time
trudeau spent the day in quebec key to
any hopes of a liberal majority but
questions about afghanistan and canada's
moral obligation to the afghan people
continue to overshadow the campaign
donna
abigail thanks the leaders of the new
democrats and conservatives were asked
about the situation in afghanistan today
too this is in part what they said
the trudeau government has failed to act
and they have abandoned people on the
ground in afghanistan
that's not canada's way that's not the
canada
of vimy ridge and juno beach it's sad to
say that that canada has failed and
justin trudeau knew about this problem
knew about the concerns and didn't act
in a timely way and as a result there's
going to be lots of people now that that
are pretty desperate and not not sure
what's going to happen to them
the afghan army's commander is feeling
betrayed we'll tell you what he had to
say a little later in the newscast plus
two months after a monstrous fire in bc
the mission to rebuild a village
we are on the unseated territories of
the musqueand squamish and zwayla tooth
nations ninety-five percent of british
columbia including vancouver is on
unseated territory meaning first nations
people never seated or legally signed
away their lands to the crown or to
canada
global national is back in a moment
british columbia is a political
battleground more than a dozen ridings
feature tight three-way races and if
justin trudeau is going to get the
majority he is seeking he needs to win
over voters here and there is a burning
issue that can't be ignored bc is still
in the midst of one of the worst forest
fire seasons on record fifteen hundred
fires so far this year forcing thousands
of people from their homes 242 active
fires are burning right now it's
recorded
the crisis is so severe it made
headlines around the world
litton liked to call itself canada's
hotspot but this was off the charts the
inferno erased the town in a few hours
it had hit 49.6 degrees celsius breaking
the canadian heat record for three
straight days
bc is not prepared for this and in
linton dozens of families have no homes
to go back to robin gill reports
donna that's all that's left of lit 95
of the village was destroyed and it's
been two months since that fire
residents are still waiting to go in to
see if any personal items can be
salvaged but they know that it's going
to take years to rebuild
i still have markings of the fire on my
face the key whistling james had no time
to flee the litten fire
she felt the hot ashes fall on her face
her arms and her legs there was so much
ash flying through the air
and i could hear the wind you know just
a week later she went back to the
village looking for her home but it was
gone just a pile of ash
and that's when it sunk in you know
everything i had was in there
now like so many of her former neighbors
she's homeless a victim of a climate
crisis the elders of this community long
predicted we knew that it was coming and
so mother earth is is heating up in the
core
and she's sending up all of these
messages and human beings are not
listening john hogan the deputy chief of
the litton first nation lost his home in
the fire too he'd never experienced heat
like this when litton hit 49.6
you wouldn't think that a place in the
interior of bc would
get that way before a place in the
mediterranean if the loss facing his
family and community isn't a wake-up
call he doesn't know what it'll take
it's here and in my books it's real the
whole village is going
the behemoth fire that wiped out the
village is known as the litton creek
fire it was first discovered june 30th
and didn't even register as a wildfire
then the winds picked up and the flames
just grew on july 7th it was 8 000
hectares by july 22nd it was almost
double that today it's 84 000 hectares
fire is ever increasing and it's going
to be an imminent danger for many more
people how do you govern a municipality
that doesn't really exist right now it's
hard jan polderman is the mayor of
litton it was a part-time job or so he
thought every day he fields calls from
residents it's hard on them they're hurt
they're angry we caught up with him
between meetings to create a new greener
community insulated with fire fences a
sprinkler system and new building bylaws
the building bylaw is meant
to create houses that are fire resistant
and what we're hoping is is that should
another firestorm begin that it'll slow
the spread
so that people have more time to
evacuate at 76 niki wiston james
welcomes this change let's start
doing preventative
it'll take at least a year before the
village gets infrastructure in place a
year after that for homes to be
constructed until then lives are on hold
the key within james says she'll wait
until the village is up and running
before she returns i could never not
want to go back to knitting that i was
born and raised there this is where my
people are
you can see this haze still hanging over
linton well it's been like this in many
parts of d.c because of months of forest
fires firefighting officials say it will
take a fall snowstorm before this fire
season can be put to rest
donna
all right robin thanks more frequent
weather extremes next how the federal
election outcome could shape canada's
climate
a summer of record heat drought and
wildfires has magnified the climate
crisis canada's federal party leaders
all have plans they say will reduce
greenhouse gas emissions eric sorensen
takes a look at those plans and whether
there are enough
if only bc's heat and wildfires this
summer were a one-time freak of nature
they're not any more so than the
unprecedented wildfires in the
mediterranean and in siberia or the
historic floods in europe and in china
you just look anywhere around the world
and you see climate catastrophe
unfolding a major u.n report says
climate change is real is indisputably
caused by humans and a hotter future is
certain we know that the climate climate
crisis is impacting us right now which
party will deliver on the ever more
urgent targets to slash carbon emissions
that come from canadian industry and
agriculture and from our homes and cars
here are the party's different plans all
with a 20 30 target date the liberals
say they will reduce emissions 40 to 45
percent below 2005 levels the
conservatives less specific point to the
harper government's targets which were
30 percent lower the ndp is promising
emissions at least 50 percent lower and
the green party 60 below those 2005
targets but our plans based on a 2015
agreement still good in 2021. following
up the paris agreement world leaders
will be pressed for more ambitious
targets at the next climate summit in
scotland this fall a new survey by ipsos
for global news found 77 percent of
canadians say this country needs to do
more on climate change the liberal
leader says he will it's going to take
even more ambition yes but even more
ability to deliver but critics say the
liberals have not delivered on targets
so far while the conservatives aren't
saying whether they'll up their targets
to keep pace with the other parties we
worked hard to have a plan that will
meet our paris reduction targets
but get people back to work meantime
construction has begun on the new tmx
pipeline extension from alberta to bc
even as the international energy agency
calls for no new oil and gas development
we do not support one single new
pipeline in canada only the green party
has called for a full halt to tmx the
liberals and conservatives backed the
pipeline and the ndp stopped short of
pulling the plug i oppose the expansion
and i think that there's better things
we can do with that money right now we
continue to have these two separate
conversations one about the oil and gas
industry one about climate and
the politicians are resisting connecting
the two a country that is among the most
dependent on fossil fuels has hard
decisions to make as canadians
increasingly confront the harsh
realities of climate change eric
sorensen global news toronto
next i speak with british columbians
about what will influence their vote
there are safe ridings but this federal
election is shaping up to be so tight
nothing can be taken for granted
i went to steveston village in richmond
bc yesterday once the epicenter of
western canada's fishing industry the
cannery is a museum now but families
still make their living fishing the
riding went conservative last time and
liberal before that
i'm trying to talk to average people and
not the experts and not the politicians
but just people okay like you so and
asking if you've decided how you're
going to vote
oh big question
sisters michelle and teresa debu are
lifelong liberals i trust trudeau he's
done what he can for this country and
he's done his very best and probably the
worst of times i was definitely happy
with trudeau and the way he handled the
pandemic at the start yeah i'm a little
bit worried about the whole afghanistan
thing right now i worry that we're
leaving you know so many behind it's not
hard to find people here who voted for
justin trudeau in the past and say they
never will again he has disappointed me
a few times in what sense in the
corruption
charges in his lies
and never fulfilling any of it to for
the truth and reconciliation report
others think trudeau only called the
election to try to get a majority oh i
have to get another yet
[Music]
last election i voted liberal and
under the liberal watch
these salmon are disappearing they've
done a very poor job of managing the
resources on the west coast
paul and lynette kershaw are selling
freshly caught chinook salmon but say
it's getting harder to make a living
this way and they don't think trudeau
gets it
minutes later look who shows up hey
we didn't know the liberal leader was
coming nor did many here there were lots
of smiles and selfies but some
unhappiness too
lynette kershaw salmon in hand tried to
seize the moment this might be the last
chinook salmon that i'm allowed to catch
others tried to avoid trudeau like donna
england who voted for him last time
i'm first nations and you know how many
people
across canada
just want running water in their village
it's something we heard from political
supporters of all the parties stop
making promises you can't keep
george o'donnell and his son both
veterans got a selfie with trudeau do
you think he deserves to be re-elected
yeah
there's nobody else they're both
sickened by the chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan it's you know another
example where you know they made
promises and didn't deliver so
it's very sad especially the lost lives
and the injuries
and that is global national for this
thursday a devastating day in
afghanistan this is how the american-led
war ends in disaster and more deaths
first signing a surrender agreement with
the taliban then abandoning the afghan
army watching the rights of girls and
women be extinguished then failing to
evacuate all of those who almost
certainly will be hunted down by the
taliban
in an essay in the new york times the
commander of the afghan army writes we
were betrayed by politics and presidents
this is not an afghan war only this was
an international war with many
militaries this was a military defeat
but it emanated from political failure
tonight's your canada is this from
political cartoonist michael to adder
thanks for watching